o ano a gente vai entrar para nos falar
não foi tirado da vaca não consegue
sempre tão procurada o seu encanto
estamos sempre à procura de alguma forma
que nos permita até para fugir a uma
pergunta e se uma escola e finanças e
foi isso aí esta pergunta ainda ficam
também mais estranha aos viciados foi
virar na escola escola da cia na questão
dos resultados não é uma escola tua
escola disso é a via está sempre ligada
aos resultados esta palavra também está
muito veloz a equipe colocar meu
psicólogo na escola é que o que vos vai
entrar nós é um jeito de trabalhar
os resultados mas eu treinei o ano com
200 crianças mais do que foi vivências e
vez que permitam esse momento ensinar a
ver com isso e aquilo que a minha escola
a oficina procura favela que além de
contribuir para a construção da pessoa
pois os jovens estão por aí trabalhar
também
portanto o projeto entregue a uma série
de alguma forma a construir os jovens
tudo isso
aqui eu só instante em que tudo criamos
algo conexão na fórmula materializará
que eu estou acreditava seu projecto
educativo e também da lan forma criar
algo força unificadora economizasse
todas as áreas da escola é isso de um
minuto ir buscá la aos objetivos do
milênio atingir até 2015
o coração das nações unidas e também a
oficina ao longo de vários anos
conquistou vários talentos nacionais
irão precisamento temos aqui os impulsos
temos aqui é garra para pensarmos em um
estado de direito nós então surgiu o
be-m fugiu aqui uma idéia que criava o
que entra entra gráfica aquela série de
vertentes escola acompanhados hoje
portanto tenha tamanho aqui um forte
desejo de associar essas questões mais
ligadas ao ambiente e também com as
questões ligadas a um contato com os
mais desfavorecidos
estes dois desafios fazem ainda mais
incrível numa altura em que o vento as
palavras do do pac é importante
cuidarmos da casa com um importante
tamanho aqui temos consciência todas as
ações nocivas que um doente mental eu
tenho feito contra o planeta informa que
o nosso também escritas vidro do
banheiro do jeito nenhum e enfim no
fundo algo que engloba quatro porteiros
uma vertente educativa o meu visual
social e também ambiental dá uma forma
acabou por ser aplicada pode ser visto
com o curso tecnológico é criativo
portanto o valor que estava a serviço
dos professores e que está à nossa vista
outras escolas
portanto pode ter computado a levantar
os estudantes dos conteúdos
matute por exemplo uma série de
disciplinas colossenses como também
contribuir para toda a parte mais
técnica mais audiovisual e multimédia e
trabalhar esses conteúdos têm também um
papel importante ao nível da educação
não formal
o movimento é maior sim o conjunto de
ações foi assaltar yada nesta
apresentação porque a economia não
voltaria a gostar eu estou aqui a falar
portanto estranho que também dá uma
forma de ensinar mas nós somos a serem
melhores que são as mais funcionários
mas próximos no ambiente no fundo
portanto está vendo que o jeito e nem
pretendo aqui explorar todas as áreas de
também saber ser saber fazer orçamentos
e vende quando quando pensamos logo
quando iniciamos o projeto e presentes
aqui como é que eu sofria construir em
piada precisamos logo que ela não
tomaria serve apenas como curso portanto
com jatos não está em ovo tempo
dirigida por outras escolas
todos os jovens a fazerem filhos a
trabalhar em história que 6 e do
ambiente e do ambiente portanto criando
assim a história as mensagens sobre o
ambiente é um conjunto enorme de
concursos da hungria foi também muito
mais anual é esse objetivo
assim nos tanques gente 39 então
desenvolveram um conjunto de ações tem
um objetivo no fundo pôr em prática os
bosques
defender então a conversa dos nossos
alunos a desenvolver um conjunto de
acções de voluntariado com o apoio das
câmaras municipais dos santos disse
também que novas americano e essas ações
eram dirigidas para diferentes públicos
alvos desde crianças até idosos e quem
não precisamente uma forte incidência
mais desfavorecidos marciais ou então
zonas o tenham mais acesso a essa
informação
as acções que estão a ver que estão aqui
a passar não tem experiência ecológico e
social passam por completo mais
informativa gás suas ruas e lançar um
novo tempo um caminho mais construtiva
mas deve por exemplo o workshop sobre
que estavam casados como fizemos com
empresas praia ou a própria plantação de
árvores
é importante sempre trabalhando aqui
então diferentes públicos alvo
recomendo aos nossos alunos da escola
estas acções ao longo de todo o ano
lectivo estão os portos assim como os
próprios ficam nos estoques sozinha
pessoal não docente que tentavam obter
aqui o autor e permitem o
desenvolvimento das ações
sem dúvida tudo isso não seria possível
se não tivessem desenvolvimento só para
ter uma idéia já estamos há mais 200
famílias ou mais de 200 alunos do pré
escolar e do 1º 5 e já realizamos 50 fãs
ao longo destes seis anos de evitar
aquilo que eu estou agora aqui passar
também passa muito tem muito a ver com o
coro da escola com o cacau é uma escola
inovadora a escola tem o seu avião em
todas as áreas das tecnologias
enfim mascola e tem de fazer com o mini
também como por exemplo como para a gala
de entrega de prémios
movimento todos os alunos estava por ser
uma criança eu trabalho pra eles
fantástica então na altura
nesta gala distribuir as tarefas
vamos tornar a escola g para espera
todas as pessoas que partilham conosco
de sonhos estão conosco paulo né
também está para além disso a escola tem
campanha está patente como estão a ver
mas é ambiental não viva ambiental e
portanto 10 sueca com essa moto é essa
uma inspiração está na exploração de
energias renováveis
o tema é o paulo novamente a é voltar o
olhar da criança voltar aqui a conectá
los e goiânia já que o que é mais
essencial
basta também aqui um caminho para passar
a mensagem do tempo tanto mais tarde
novamente inovar nos dias que estava em
terceiro justas limpas assim mas a todos
não só aqui neste cantinho que estamos
aqui muito confortável dentro da unidade
mas também a nível global irão aparecer
amanhã a um susto porém não parecer
muito português no estrangeiro
neste ano também nos iam
as imagens estão ativas da ouviu aqui e
falar que eu sou o dunga já tem algum
mega patrocinador ou então a um título à
minha página que os colocou o inter na
explicação própria sempre sabem que eu
tenho aqui ela vai na com os da sola e
caminho e isso é sexy do mundo até
porque pensar no lado bom
assim o governo não lembro dos jogos na
própria escola
viemos só pode ser combatida com 10 fui
será o alicerce destreza dos títulos
vivências irão medir todos nós só eu
vou-me formas e barra e também aprender
a olhar para novas formas de trabalhar
por uma causa maior que é o planeta
agora precisamos agora são umas imagens
o meu melhor